hey guys welcome to this simply learned
session on ai applications in 2020
so here's a small refresher about
artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence refers to
intelligence displayed by machines
that simulates human intelligence
basically it's the ability of a machine
or a program to think
and learn now that you're all caught up
let's take a look at how different
domains are using ai
let's have a look at the current market
state of ai
according to a tractica a market
research firm the global ai market is
expected to reach a revenue of 118
billion dollars by 2025.
next according to the research firm
gartner ai usage has grown by 270
percent in the last four years
a clear indication of the growth that's
yet to come in the upcoming years
in fact 87 percent of companies that
actually have adopted ai
were using it to improve email marketing
and in some news that could be positive
or negative
depending on how you look at it 75
countries are now using ai technology
for surveillance
now let's have a look at how artificial
intelligence is used in different
domains
first off ai applications in e-commerce
ai offers you personalized shopping with
ai you have a recommendation engine
through which you can engage
better with your customers these
recommendations are made by taking into
consideration their usage history their
preferences
and interests by providing these
recommendations
what you're doing is basically improving
your relationship with your customers
you are improving their loyalty towards
your brand and by extension
causing an increase in the number of
conversions with ai you can provide
users the ability to perform
visual searches users can upload an
image of the item they require
search results are shown that match
their query so all of this can be done
without them having to type a single
word
next we have ai powered assistance
assistants like virtual shopping
assistants
and chat bots help improve use
experience while shopping online
for this techniques like nlp or natural
language processing are used to make the
conversation
sound as human and personal as possible
did you know that soon customer service
could be handled by chatbot on
amazon.com
moreover these assistants can have
real-time engagement with your customers
they can handle multiple situations like
if the customer has some feedback the
chatbot will take it from them
or if they have some basic questions
about your brand the chatbot can help
them out
these assistants can help further
emphasize the point to the users about
how important they are to your
organization
next under e-commerce we have smart
purchasing
customer trends are often difficult to
predict
but with ai they don't have to be ai can
forecast demands related to a particular
product
with this knowledge your decisions on
what products to stock up and when it
needs to be done
can be positively impacted doing this
you're meeting customer expectations and
improving
their experience with your brand finally
under e-commerce we have fraud
prevention
two of the biggest issues that
e-commerce companies have to deal with
are credit card fraud and fake reviews
by taking into consideration usage
patterns
ai can help deal with reducing the
possibility of credit card frauds taking
place
talking about fake reviews did you know
that more than 80 percent of customers
decide to buy
a product or service based on their
customer reviews
ai can help identify and handle fake
reviews
by making sure they're handled you are
improving customer trust in your brand
and products
some of the organizations that have
already started ai
are amazon alibaba.com and ebay based on
research performed by mit
gps technology can provide users with
accurate timely and detailed information
to improve safety
the technology uses a combination of
conventional neural networks and graph
neural network
which makes lives easier for users by
automatically determining the number of
lanes and road types behind
obstructions on the roads next up we
have ai
applications and robotics first off
let's have a look at mobility
robots that are powered by ai will use
real-time updates
they would be able to maneuver through a
particular part of travel
with this path the robot can sense
obstacles in its path and then pre-plan
its journey
it can be used for carrying goods in
factories warehouses and
hospitals cleaning offices and large
equipments
inventory management and it is also used
for exploring environments that are too
dangerous for humans
ai can also be used in process
optimization
data obtained by sensors can be analyzed
to enhance ai intelligence
with this knowledge unnecessary
breakdowns are prevented
and it can also reduce associated costs
of major issues
next up let's see how ai is applied in
the human resources domain
now this is something most people
wouldn't have expected
did you know that companies use software
to ease the hiring process
artificial intelligence helps with blind
hiring
software that uses machine learning can
be used to sift through applications
based on specific parameters
ai can be used to scan job candidates
profiles and resumes to provide
recruiters an understanding of the
talent pool they must choose from
now let's have a look at ai applications
in healthcare
first off let's have a look at how ai is
used in patient care
so there are these things called
prescription errors which are basically
caused due to slips lapses or mistakes
in a doctor's prescription
let's face it a dosage too high can be
the difference between life and death
audit systems that use ai can help
prevent these kinds of errors from being
handled
and the diseases are properly identified
some of the popular uses are jvon
analytic and well frame next let's see
how ai is used with medical imaging and
diagnostics
ai can help with early diagnosis to
analyze chronic conditions taking into
consideration laboratory
and other medical data it is also used
with advanced medical imaging through
which you can analyze and transform
images through this you can create
models for possible scenarios
next up is ai applications in research
and development
ai is really important when it comes to
the discovery of new drugs
this is made possible with the help of a
combination of historical data and
medical intelligence
it also helps understand the human gene
and its components
it also helps predict the different
outcomes possible if gene editing is
performed
right now there's probably scientists
racing to develop the gene sequence for
covid19 and towards the creation of the
vaccine
now that we have reached midwest i have
a question to ask
are you guys using ai powered software
in your workplace
let me know in the live chat if you
enjoy watching informative tech videos
like this one consider subscribing to
simply learn's channel to stay up to
date on the trending technologies
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update in the future
next up let's talk about ai applications
in agriculture
first off ai helps with monitoring crop
and soil health
it can help with identifying defects and
nutrient deficiency in the soil
by analyzing images of soil and patterns
in them
soil defects plant pests and diseases
can be identified
next ai helps decrease pesticide usage
using technology like computer vision
robotics and machine learning
using this kind of technology it can be
determined where weeds are grown
this way herbicides can be sprayed only
where the weeds are
with this herbicide usage is limited ai
also helps with agriculture bots it can
be used to reduce human labor by
harvesting crops at a faster rate and a
higher volume
next let's have a look at artificial
intelligence in gaming
one of the most important things that
game companies need to handle which is
labor costs
this is done to generate levels maps
textures weapons characters etc
ai can be used to create smart
human-like npcs to interact with players
it can also be used to predict human
behavior using which game design
and testing can be improved now this
example isn't a recent one but that of a
2014 game called alien isolation
now if you know about the movies you
know it's from the alien series of
movies
so in this game the titular alien stalks
the player throughout the game
the alien uses two ais to hunt the
player
a director ai that always knows the
position of the location of the player
and an alien ai which is driven by
sensors and behaviors that constantly
hunt the player
the director ai only gives the alien ai
clues to the player's location which it
needs to figure out
now let's have a look at ai application
in automobiles
first off we have driverless automobiles
by taking a combination of information
obtained from the vehicle's camera radar
cloud services
gps and control signals that can be used
to operate the vehicle
it's thanks to all of this that the car
is able to drive itself
next ai offers driver assistance ai can
be used to improve the in-vehicle
experience as well systems like
emergency braking blind spot monitoring
driver asset steering are used
next up ai and social media first let's
see how facebook is able to use ai
one of the ways ai is being used is for
analyzing pictures
this can be used to identify the people
in an image ai is also used in a tool
called deep text
so with the help of ai can be used to
analyze posts that represent suicidal
thoughts
the tool can also be used to translate
posts from different languages
next let's have a look at ai used by
instagram
ai takes into account your likes and the
accounts you follow to determine what
posts you are shown on your explore tab
the deep text tool has also been used
recently to identify and remove spam
messages from user accounts
ai is also used for handling
cyberbullying to check content based on
hashtags from other users
next up ai and twitter ai is used to
determine fraud propaganda and hateful
content on the platform
it is also used to recommend tweets that
the users might enjoy based on what
tweets that you engage with
it is also used to filter through
inappropriate content and
it from the platform ai is also used for
automatically cropping images based on
face recognition
it is also used to filter through
inappropriate content and remove it from
the platform
ai is also used for automatically
cropping images based on face
recognition
and finally let's have a look at ai
applications and marketing
first off ai enables programmatic
advertising
ai enables highly targeted and
personalized ads by taking into
consideration behavioral analysis
pattern recognition
and much more ai also enables you to
re-target audiences at
right time to make sure they are given
appropriate results
and ensure feelings of annoyance and
distrust next up does
personalized narratives ai can help with
content marketing in a way that matches
the brand style and voice
it can also be used to handle routine
tasks like performance campaign reports
and much more
then ai helps with setting up chat bots
chatbots are powered by ai natural
language processing natural language
generation natural language
understanding that can understand what
the user's language
and respond in the ways humans do then
we have personalized ui and ux
it can be used to provide users with
real-time personalization
basically these smart systems can
process information about site visitors
or app users
then apply changes to the model in ways
that optimize it for future use
by continually learning and adjusting
the algorithms improves the user's
experience to offer a more engaging
personalized experience
next ai helps with localization it can
help with editing
and optimizing market campaigns to fit
the needs of the local market
by automated editing of certain
variables like ctas ad copies etc the
campaigns would be able to connect
better with a local audience
and there you go these are the top
applications of ai
in 2020. with that we have reached the
end of this video
do you agree with our list thank you for
watching this video and stay tuned for
more from simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here